Well,
thanks.
Thanks for having us today.
We're actually excited to be here and appreciate the opportunity to come in and
tell you a little bit.
Um,
what the five interest Colorado is about.
you know,
I think the place to start is entrepreneurship and you might think to yourself,
why are we talking about entrepreneurship with work that you do in prisons?
And our belief is,
is that entrepreneurship is actually one of the keys to giving people a second
chance who are incarcerated within the state of Colorado as well as in the
United States.
And so you might think to yourself,
well,
what does that mean to be an entrepreneur?
You know,
how are you teaching entrepreneurship?
And I think what we have found,
the best way to do that is just to give you a short glimpse into what happens
into one of our prisons.
And so I'm just going to play for you a short video that I'm about 60 seconds
long.
Colorado should be the worst place to commit a violent crime,
the best place to get a second chance.
I think what defy does,
it defies the odds.
It defies the traditional way of looking at,
at rehabilitation and kind of creates its own energy,
its own hurricane,
a possibility.
My goodness,
this is a happy day.
We're showing that we can become more than our past.
So what do you think maybe not what you expect to be happening in prisons,
particularly in our,
um,
more secure prisons within the state.
And you probably got a sense from watching that video,
the energy,
but also the passion that came from the community.
You may be even recognized a few of the faces.
And part of the reason we love coming out to the community,
particularly here in boulder to talk with everyone,
is to fight.
It was very much born out of the passion for innovation here in Boulder.
And I don't know if anybody recognizes,
obviously we have the former governor up here,
Brad Feld,
a couple of other people from the foundry group and the foundry group.
We're really the proponents to bring defy ventures to Colorado.
Um,
that passion for entrepreneurship,
that passion of bringing the community together to try to solve when a society's
problems.
And so our goal here today is to spend the next 10 to 15 minutes to tell you a
little bit about defy ventures,
Colorado,
the kind of the what,
the why and the how.
And I'm going to have our program manager Stacy Pooka come up and do that.
And before we moved to that,
you know,
I just want to encourage everybody in the room.
Our goal today is to make this as interactive as possible and so we'll have
plenty of time for Q and a at the end.
But if anybody has any questions,
feel free to ask them at any point.
When we get done with our overview of the program from Stacy,
we've actually got a very diverse panel here who brings quite differing
perspectives,
um,
from the incarcerated sector in terms of talking about defy the program,
but more importantly how we can all come together to solve this issue.
And so with that,
I'm going to turn it over to Stacy will come up and talk about the program.
So defy ventures,
Colorado was born out of the idea that we're all ex some things we think about
our past.
We can all think of something that we've done that we're not necessarily proud
of and we believe in second chances and providing those second chances through
entrepreneurship.
We do that in a really unique way that most programs that work with people with
criminal histories aren't able to do that.
We're very lucky to do so.
We start inside presents and we provide an eight month long program called CEO
of your new life where individuals engage in character development,
career readiness and entrepreneurial education.
So you can see up here from our very complicated program diagram that we start
inside the facilities and then we can,
can you to work with people once they are released from incarceration.
Um,
there are a few things that we do with them when they are released.
One is a,
they go through what's called pathways to reentry where they basically,
um,
get stable in the community housing,
healthcare,
jobs,
financial stability,
so that they don't need to revert to old ways of thinking or being,
um,
they're stable.
Once they're stable within their communities,
they can go into our business incubator where they then learn to actually start
and run their own small business that they planned and worked on while they were
currently incarcerated.
So you can see that our mission is to transform the lives of people with
criminal histories along the entrepreneurial journey.
The reason that we do this is because America has a prison crisis.
We have 5% of the world's population,
but 20% of the world's incarcerated population,
30% of 23 year olds have a criminal history.
So whether you're watching this on your computer or you're sitting in the
audience,
how many of you can think of something really stupid that you did before the
time you were 23?
Yeah,
we think that's really early to start writing people off.
Uh,
people who go to prison,
67% of them are rearrested and go back to prison within three years of being
released in Colorado,
it's 45%.
Having criminal history makes it
significantly difficult to get and maintain employment.
Um,
people who have a criminal history have employment rates that are 20% 27% lower
than other people.
And by checking the box,
I have a felony history on a job application,
reduces their chances of getting a call back from an employer by 50%.
So not only do we have a program in prison that's eight months long where they
work on character development,
entrepreneurship and career readiness,
we bring in volunteers to help them along that journey.
So last year alone,
we brought in over 340 volunteers.
We brought in 450 to Googlers in our counterpart counterpart in northern
California.
So googler's have been involved in this for a very long time in northern
California and we're looking to get a Googlers here in Colorado involved as
well.
The secret sauce to what works,
why this program works is the community that we built around the people who are
currently incarcerated.
It's very rare for someone who's incarcerated to see anyone else other than
correctional officers and their family members.
So to have these opportunities to talk about character development,
career readiness and business with top executives.
And empathetically minded people from the community allows them an extra
advantage to success once they reintegrate into society that most people don't
have.
So on that theme of building community and having this community travel with the
people in our program,
from the inside to the outside,
I'm going to bring Bob back up and he's going to introduce some of our key
stakeholders in the community who are going to give you guys a little bit more
information.
So why don't we start with,
go down the line.
Just start with a brief intro.
You know,
a lot of it will come out as we go through our panel,
but maybe spend one or two minutes just telling us a little bit about yourself
and why you're here today.
And we'll start next to me with Brandon
some.
My name is Brannon Hagans on the gang intelligence supervisor at Colorado state
penitentiary.
Um,
Colorado state penitentiaries where we keep probably the most dangerous
offenders in the state of Colorado.
And we were actually the first facility.
Where are we?
The first facility.
We were the first facility to give this this program go.
Initially when we were told that they were going to come in and this is what
they wanted to do,
it scared us just because of our federal population.
Um,
so we sat down and we picked 20 guys that we thought we could put in a room
without them trying to kill each other,
um,
and keeping these wonderful individuals safe.
And it worked out.
And from that initial class,
just the amount of guys that are wanting to get into this and participate in it.
I mean it's just been amazing.
Our violence within our facility has dropped off drastically.
I can't give you percentages,
but I can tell you being there day in and day out that are violence has dropped
because these guys want to get in this program.
They want to do better for themselves and learn something.
Hello,
my name is Bob Buckholtz.
I worked for the Colorado Department of Corrections.
I work at the Arkansas Valley correctional facility,
but it's about two hours east of Pueblo.
Um,
and defy has,
from what we can tell has made a huge difference in our population as far as
having an offenders involved in the program have bled over to them talking to
staff,
which before,
I mean,
that's kind of a,
the no man's land as far as offenders wanting to talk to staff.
Um,
and defy when they're working on their programs,
um,
the offenders are working on their,
their plans.
They ended up coming,
asking staff for input,
which is,
is really neat.
That's really,
it's a really neat opportunity for us and them.
Okay.
Hi.
Um,
my name is Ronnie Madrid and I am an entrepreneur and training of graduate from
the first class and Colorado state penitentiary.
I agree.
It's,
it's been amazing.
I had to work my butt off to get into that class and it absolutely changed the
path that I was taking before simply because
the people with defy who came in as well as this gentleman right here day.
There are the first ones,
probably throughout my whole life actually gave me a chance and seeing that I
wanted to do better so I can be better.
And,
um,
I,
I've been able to present myself to the world working while I'm working on being
scores my best.
And it's because of the things that I have around me now,
the people that I have around me now from what I learned about myself in
transition from being
a gang member,
a drug dealer,
um,
somebody who made terrible choices throughout his life to a single father who
wants to learn how to cook.
Oh,
my kids don't have to eat hot pockets in who?
In he pebbles.
And like they helped me when I,
when I'm out here like there is,
he's always asking if she can help me with anything.
It really does extend from the inside out when not a lot of programs do that are
imposed.
The Department of Corrections.
Thank you.
Hey,
I'm Tom Layman.
Um,
I'm a volunteer in the community.
I'm on the defy ventures Colorado advisory board.
Uh,
he used to work at Google Boulder Office,
um,
for six years a while back.
Now I'm with a company called building ventures.
But,
um,
yeah,
I've been,
I've been a volunteer with defy Colorado for for about a year.
Oh,
first sought from a Brad Feld blog post.
He was talking about his experience in prison and how,
I mean the enthusiasm just completely came through on the blog post and at the
end after describing his whole day and what it was like,
um,
he had a Bob's email at the bottom and so I emailed Bob to find out how,
you know,
what's the story with this thing?
And he and Stacy and I went out to lunch and um,
then Stacy is,
he and I went in to prison and um,
yeah,
I lost track how many times I've gone back.
It's,
it's been a wonderful thing.
Oh Great.
You got,
my name is Travis Taylor and that wonderful,
beautiful human being that you see to my left and your right with the long hair
and glasses.
He and I are four years in,
four hours apart.
He is my younger brother.
His name is Darrius Taylor.
I am the very,
very proud brother of anarchic solve Allen,
a correctional facility EIT in graduate.
Uh,
I met Bob at,
uh,
my little brother's graduation.
And to say the meeting was life changing is,
does not do it justice.
Uh,
defy in order for it to reach the communities the way that we expected,
we will need,
uh,
people such as yourselves to see what we see.
And part of that is going to be today and I hope you become as excited about
joining the fi and having it do what it did in my life and in my family's life
for you and yours.
So I thank you all for being here.
That's great.
So we've got
about as diverse as you can get in this issue to people who actually work inside
the prisons.
Somebody who was in prison and then two volunteers and one who brings the family
perspective that's there.
You know,
the question I would like to go to and um,
I guess I'm going to do this because the two people who drove the farthest,
Bob,
you drove what,
about three and a half hours to come up here for an hour or bringing in about
two and a half hours is
why'd you do that?
I mean,
why did you get in the car and drive up here and come here and talk and explain
the perspective from your standpoint.
Bob,
do you want to go first?
Sure.
You know,
I made the trip because defy has,
like I stated earlier,
it has made it a huge impact for us on the prison population.
MMM.
He was actually impressive when the first day they came in there.
We had over a hundred offenders
and um,
they started,
it started off the program there.
It was amazing how they could control the offender population
in that room.
Um,
the respect that happened between the volunteers and the actual offenders in the
room was just incredible and it was really nice for us to see a staff working in
there because we're there to help.
We're not there to punish the courts have already done that.
Our job as to help out for them to be successful.
And it's great because when you looked at defies a mission statement,
it actually leads right into our mission statement,
which is a successful reentry of all offenders back into society.
So it really matches up well.
That's worked very well.
Um,
it keeps him busy.
He can walk through at night,
um,
do cell checks,
look in the doors,
they're actually working on their business plan.
They take it serious.
So it's been been a really,
really good program and we believe in Brandon,
what about you?
So for me,
coming from a CSP in,
in just the clientele that we have there,
when we initially walked these guys into the room to start this program,
um,
usually when they leave the day hall,
they're fully restrained.
Wrists,
ankles,
they've got handcuffs everywhere.
And this was the first time we ever took these individuals and put them in our
visiting room and took the cuffs off with a bunch of volunteers.
And it was,
it was kind of hairy.
It,
it didn't feel right for the environment.
But once they got rolling with the program,
I mean these guys were standing up hugging each other and you know,
the whole time I'm thinking,
please don't hurt anybody but this,
this program gave them hope.
You know,
with the volunteers coming in,
a lot of these guys,
they don't get family to come in.
They don't have much communication at all.
And when the volunteers come in,
they give them a sense of being a sense of hope,
a sense of purpose.
And it's just amazing to see their faces light up,
the changes they make,
their demeanor,
their attitudes.
It's,
it's just amazing to watch these guys change.
Ron,
I want to direct this next question to you cause I think what would be
beneficial for the people here in the level of watching on video is to
understand that that initial engagement point,
right.
We didn't talk about it earlier,
but real quickly the defy program is an eight month program.
I would describe it as intensive,
obviously would love your opinion on that hour or two day to stay up with it.
Why did you come into the program and then what kept you going through those
eight months?
Because obviously there were the ups and downs of life that were happening as
you went through that.
Okay.
I came into the program because it's an entrepreneurship program.
I was in prison for a distribution case.
Um,
I gang banged my whole life.
I,
it's my wife 18 months ago to a drug overdose,
she started using drugs.
Same that I was selling.
Um,
she lost her life.
Eventually after it,
our kids were separated.
I'm still fighting for my kids right now.
And so when,
when that stuff started to happen to me and I seen where my life was headed,
I realized that it was time for me to absolutely make a change on our,
I was in a diet prison and at that point,
most important thing to me was family.
And I have a job right now.
I'm in a halfway house.
I got out December 26th and it's the third job that I've ever had in my life.
Um,
but the entrepreneurship program,
when I went in there and we were working on our resumes and like our job skills
or realize that I have marketing,
distribution,
quality control,
customer surveys,
like how all of these,
I have all of these skills that I can try that are transferable skills that got
Stacy as you know,
you could do these.
And I realized I absolutely can.
And I will.
Um,
right now I'm trying to get it approved with the halfway house for me to go to
metro state.
Um,
I want to go for organizational communication so I can be,
um,
you know,
a mentor or a consultant,
I want to be able to,
you know,
just just passed the buck.
I also want to look into some,
you know,
certification for addictions counseling,
um,
simply because I've been on both sides of the dope game.
I've been in the streets.
Um,
I was a gang leader from my neighborhood and I walked away and that was the
scariest to walk away from the streets.
It was the scariest thing that I've ever done in my life because I had,
I had made it through the ups and the downs,
the Colorado state penitentiary.
Um,
I dunno if he's are aware,
but it's the absolute worst at the state of Colorado has to offer as far as
punishment minus the death penalty.
Um,
you,
you go to prison,
you're getting in trouble,
you get in trouble in prison,
you go to the hole,
you get,
you keep getting in trouble.
They send you a book to Colorado State Penitentiary and it's a war zone.
It's a war zone.
Um,
they let us out for breakfast and everybody's running to the shower so they
could go get their shower because we might've been locked down for six,
seven days because of the stabbing or salt or something like that.
And as soon as three,
four minutes later,
it's due to do to first responders and it's literally a war zone.
But when the fire came and we were ready to go every Tuesday,
I was like,
I'm gone.
I'm leaving this place.
I'm getting some sanity on Canton,
you know,
some piece for a while because everybody in that program,
it was like,
this is not what we're doing.
This is what we're doing for us tomorrow.
We can leave all the politics and all the prison stuff back at the house.
And everybody did it.
And I don't know how these people did it.
I don't know how Bob and Stacy and the volunteers and everybody came in,
but they did it.
I got seriously.
This man right here said they do arcs and people are doing their homework and
their big books like this,
and I would literally stay in my room some days for two,
three hours thinking about what I need to say for this answer because it
affected me because I really wanted that change and these people really put
forth the effort and the time and were patient with us.
They literally laid on the floor with us and we're like,
we're here.
We got something.
If you want to accept it,
fine.
You know what I mean?
We're willing to give it to all the way through and they followed through.
You know,
it started in the inside.
I came out and this is the best I've ever done in my life.
This is the best I've ever done in my life.
I know for sure I'll be a multimillionaire or five years of the jeep.
Seriously,
but
that's great.
I think that's interesting,
right?
As we go down the line,
we hear the impact in prisons.
We hear the impact Ron and your life.
But I want to switch to hear about the impact that Tom and Travis have seen,
both from themselves in the community.
But I think Travis,
I want to start with you is also talk a little bit about the impact you've seen
in your brother.
Um,
Darya Sue's at Arkansas Valley.
So,
oh,
usually I tell the story about,
you know,
my brother and how he wound up,
uh,
in prison.
But listening to that,
I want to back up just a second.
So when my brother first went to prison the first time,
uh,
it was in 2001 or 2008,
he went from 2000 to 2005,
he's in the federal penitentiary and he was prosecuted under something called
project exile,
where if you carry a gun,
illegal gun in the state of Colorado,
you automatically got a five year federal prison.
Since don't pass,
go.
Don't collect $200.
Don't say hi to your mom.
You're gone.
My brother was 19 years old.
My brother went to prison at 19 way.
He was five four five five weighing 140 pounds.
My brother came out of prison weighing 215 pounds
and
he looked like one of them action figures from Batman or something.
Now the rest of us were like,
oh,
okay.
Well my brother stayed free.
Exactly six weeks,
six weeks.
That second time
they sent my brother away for 44 years.
Let that sink in your head for a second 44 years.
The problem with that is my brother wasn't doing 44 years alone.
My mother,
myself,
my father,
his sister,
nieces,
nephews,
we all got that 44 year prison sentence.
We all got the five year prison sentence.
We all got the six weeks furlough.
So my brother never understood this concept.
No matter how many times we tried to talk to him,
there was a period where I didn't write,
speak,
or talk to my brother.
He'd write letters.
I take the letters and someday if I ever see y'all again,
I'll show you.
I kept the box and Yo,
y'all didn't know this.
I kept the box of the unopened letters because I didn't feel he deserved my
energy or time to read another excuse another,
I won't happen again because it kept happening.
Even when he was in prison,
it kept happening.
Then defy comes along and I'm going to kind of speed it up.
Now the fire comes along and his entire thought pattern of how he processed
information changed the way he carried himself.
Change the way you started talking changed.
He said something that I'd never heard him say before to visit and he goes,
I did.
Excuse me.
What Hon?
What?
He said I did.
I did everything they said I did.
I did it all.
I made that mistake but that was me then.
That's not me now.
So while you're healing this visit,
you have a choice.
You can,
you can keep looking at me for who I was or you can look at me for what?
I'm trying to be calm.
I have seen my brother virtually every weekend since that meeting.
I was proud to go to his graduation.
I walked up to Bob,
cause they don't,
they,
you weren't supposed to get up and walk around like,
cause it's a prison,
you know,
you weren't supposed to be moving.
But the guy that saw me was like,
hey,
you know,
I was like,
can I go talk to this guy?
And I'm pointing to Bob and he's like,
ah,
I ain't see it.
So I jumped up and I run over to Bob and he's in the middle of talking to
somebody and I'm trying to keep it together,
but I can't stop crying.
And it wasn't sadness.
It was absolutely elation because I had never seen my brother graduate from
anything but a prison sentence to another prison sentence.
That's all I had seen.
And now I see my brother walked around with his chest out,
his head's up.
Amy's recognizing not only what he was but who we can become.
And I'll walk through the Barb and I told him,
I said,
Bob,
listen,
I own a company.
It's a,
it's a finance company.
I make a little bit of money,
not like this,
but I make some money.
And I said,
Bob,
whatever you want,
I'll write you a check.
They'll do whatever you need,
whatever you need.
He was like,
I don't really know you,
but okay,
cool.
And I'm sitting there like,
I love you people.
When he was like,
I just met you.
I was like,
no,
I still love you.
Right.
And he and Stacy gave myself and a gentleman in the back there is my business
partner named Gil dads and young young lady in their main Kayla go lady.
She just got married,
everybody okay with La.
Um,
and they decided to help me with Bob and Stacy and easy and listening to you.
I can only imagine what that felt like walking out the door and changing your
life for the good.
These two gentlemen,
you know,
we were not going to knock them forward.
They do for their,
for their living.
Cause they,
they,
they have a purpose,
but I'm certain they're happy to hear that they will never meet you in their
professional life again.
Right.
And that's,
that's really what this is about.
That's what I guess you wanted me to tell you.
I'm not going to bore you with all the family history,
but the bottom line is my little brother is now a different person and it would
have never happened.
Listened to me very closely.
They say,
never use the word,
never.
It would have never happened without Bob and Stacy.
My brother came from a two parent home.
My Dad was in the military,
my mom was a registered dietician.
We all went to college.
He had a football scholarship.
There was absolutely no reason for him to ever join a gang,
let alone put that monstrosity that's on his back.
But he did
and now he's understanding that he did not belong in prison
except to learn.
The life he had was a blessing.
You've learned the life that you have is a blessing no matter what environment
you're in.
Defy gave that back to my family and as I told you then I'll tell you now for
the rest of my life,
whatever you need,
whenever you need it,
you call
and I hope you do.
And I think the Fi forgiving my family and opportunity to have my brother back.
And I think you for all your hard work,
he stay on him while you in there
and bring my brother home because I know once he comes home,
the only time we'll ever think about you is when we see you at a five it because
you will never see them in your professional capacity again.
And I thank you and define Stacy for all of that and I hope all of you join us
with working with the fire.
I really do.
It'll change your lives cause it changed hours.
Well what,
so let me just jump in because what are we really saying here,
right?
I mean we've,
yeah,
I mean let's just reframe it.
We,
we,
we don't have a shortage of people in prisons,
right?
We don't have a shortage of programs in prisons,
These,
these are one off situations with Ronnie,
with Dario Sucks Cetera.
That's here.
You know,
I have my belief of what we're talking about here,
which is this issue of volunteerism and collective community impact.
What I'm actually interested following on Travis,
this point,
Tom,
is to hear from you what,
what's been your experience as a volunteer?
I mean,
you didn't,
assuming you'd never been in a prison before,
before you came in with the five for the first time,
you know,
before we talked about what 340 plus volunteers that came in in 2018 who made
the two and a half hour drive from boulder and places.
I mean,
how many times have you been to prison with us?
I'm not sure.
I have sort of lost count.
Yeah.
I mean it easily has to be about five.
I mean,
it's double digits,
but,
um,
but what is it from your perspective?
Right.
You don't,
you don't come with Travis as background of having a loved one who had been in
prison.
Um,
okay.
What is it from that perspective,
from the volunteer's perspective you think that makes it work?
Well,
I think,
you know,
what motivates you to go in and then what your experience is once you're in
inner sort of two different stories.
And I think the thing that motivated me to go in is
yeah,
it's probably a little fuzzy.
You know,
as I get older I'm more curious about,
okay.
Different People's experiences,
um,
more may be aware of,
of,
um,
some of the benefits I've had in my life.
Um,
but,
but mostly
I'm kind of a sucker for a cause and I didn't know if this was going to be,
you know,
I didn't know this is going to be done because I just thought it was an
interesting thing to do.
And so,
um,
okay.
I talked to Bob and Stacy and they made it sound great and so I hopped in the
car and drove dark and South Valley.
Okay.
It's a long drive and it's a long time to think about,
okay,
wow,
I'm going to walk into a prison.
To me,
I really been in a prison that's um,
okay,
maybe that's a little bit out of my comfort zone.
Maybe I wonder why I signed up for this.
Exactly.
Um,
he,
and so you go in,
or at least I went in,
um,
with,
with Stacy.
Is He that first time?
It was to,
to speak to a class.
Um,
every,
every week there's a class with a,
a different topic.
And I think I was talking about,
um,
sort of personal brand and,
and raising money and,
and that sort of thing.
And,
um,
I walked in the room
and
all these guys were in green,
just sort of made a beeline right for me.
Everyone had a giant grin on their face and their handout and it wasn't like
that polite,
well,
it's very nice to meet you.
It was like they were site to see me and I wasn't exactly sure why they were
psyched to see me,
but it was like this instant acceptance that you don't get when you're just sort
of walk into a business meeting.
And,
um,
so that felt,
I mean it was immediately at feeling comfortable with the whole thing.
And um,
I got on with my presentation and,
uh,
we were talking about ways to fund your company,
so,
you know,
we're talking about,
I mean,
bootstrapping or friends and family round or an angel or venture or whatever.
And somebody raised their hand and said,
hey,
what about a bank loan?
And I started to answer and realized,
you know,
I've never really been involved in one of those transactions with a startup with
a bank loan.
And so I started to explain it,
you know,
this isn't something I have a lot of experience in.
And this guy in the back row,
one of the EIT is a back row,
raises his hand.
He's like,
excuse me.
Uh,
the first company that I started actually we started with a bank loan.
I could address this if you'd like.
And this guy gave a great explanation of how that works.
And it was at that moment that I realized,
wow,
I totally sold these guys short.
And as you listen to the questions they asked and the points they made,
um,
there were a bunch of very sharp,
super motivated people in that room and you realize,
oh my gosh,
there's a ton of potential locked up in this space.
Um,
I think the other thing above the totally motivated me was,
um,
the way these guys make themselves vulnerable.
I mean,
part of every,
every session starts with,
okay,
MMM,
commitments,
thank you,
commitments and affirmations.
And one of them is,
um,
I will be vulnerable.
And you know,
you just,
you just know from life experience that you can have so much better conversation
with someone.
You can learn so much more from them and then they can get more from you if you
allow yourselves to make yourself vulnerable.
What'd you think about it in prison?
That's probably the last thing that you want to be is,
is vulnerable.
Yeah.
Um,
and so the fact that they could come into this room and have so much trust in
each other and the volunteers and they can just flip that switch and be
completely open and vulnerable for a couple hours and then go back to the
regular life and turn that off.
I mean,
to me that just showed they're willing to
make a giant leap to make this work.
That cannot be an easy thing.
Um,
and I think that was one of the things that partly sold me on the effort that
they put into it,
but partly just made it so much more rewarding for me and made us such a
privilege to spend time with these guys and get to know him a little bit.
And you know,
I think that's an interesting point on the vulnerability and,
and you know,
Ron,
I want to to come back to you and your experience being on the inside.
You know,
we use the word Eit,
entrepreneur and training,
which everybody who comes into our program,
you know,
that's what their title is.
What was the impact of that volunteers and those volunteers coming into the
facility week after week,
not only how to kind of tie into your personal journey,
but how did it tie into that aspect of vulnerability of people feeling like,
you know,
they can kind of not let their guard down,
for lack of a better term,
but to work on what's important in terms of making transformational change.
Well the thing is,
is everybody in prison wants to change every single person.
I don't care who it is,
everyone,
everyone is tired of it.
Especially repeat offenders.
Um,
I'm a repeat offender actually doing all your brother that we were,
we started out together at the same time in prison and um,
he had just got out of the feds and I was on my way back to prison.
We were in Denver County together.
We used to worry,
that's good friend of mine.
I just haven't seen him forever.
But um,
especially repeat offenders were always like,
I'm so tired of this.
I'm tired of tired of it.
I'm tired of it.
But there was never anything available to us simply because of our jackets,
our background of who we are on paper.
Um,
the recidivism rate stays high because nobody knows who we are because nobody
gives us the chance.
Up until very recently,
I stopped.
I grew up in the juvenile system and spent about 13 and a half years of my adult
life in the adult system and I take full responsibility for the choices that I
made and sentences were deserved.
They were deserved because I was making poor life choices and I was where I
needed to be.
Going back to what I said in the beginning,
everybody wants to change.
Everybody wants to change.
And even when we speak up and when I call,
I want to do this no more.
Up until very recently,
the department of Corrections hasn't been the department of Corrections.
It never corrected behavior.
It was the department of confinement.
They would lock us up and CSP,
they just opened it up.
Um,
it's a close facility now,
but I did six years in solitary confinement because of the choices that I made
in cider prison.
Huh.
And um,
nobody cared about what I wanted to do because I was just like everybody else.
Like I said,
everybody inside wants to change and they speak it.
I don't want to do this no more.
The fact of the matter is,
it's another world inside.
Um,
being vulnerable is the last thing that you want to be in prison.
You have to be an Alpha male or you're going to be somebody,
something that you don't want to be,
you're going to be the victim of something or somebody.
And
when the fire would bring their volunteers and you know,
all of us,
we couldn't wait to go to class on Tuesday and because it was five hours away
from,
you know,
the craziest stuff that you could imagine,
uh,
you never,
you never realize what people could do to people.
Um,
when you,
when you're in a war zone and you go into them classes and,
um,
these people right here,
they would come up and
they didn't look at you like that.
They wanted to hear what you actually had to say about your business or about
your day or about your family,
um,
about what you wanted to do.
And they really wanted to help you.
Every conversation that I had with anybody,
um,
as far as the volunteer that came up,
they've,
they've held true to their word.
They seriously have held true to that word.
And I feel like the way to lower the recidivism rate is for people to get to
know who we are.
You know,
we're not a product of our land and our environments.
We're just product the choices that we've made.
Sometimes we didn't know any better on her and everything in life through trial
and error.
I didn't have a dad or a big brother or anybody to show me on.
My parents were there.
Um,
I've been on my own since I was 13,
so
when they would come in and just get to know us and see who the type of people
who we are and not the crime that we committed,
it made them look at us different.
So if you guys want to lower the recidivism rate,
his Colorado,
get to know some criminals who want to change,
you know,
be volunteers.
Go up and speak with the people after the five minutes,
even if it's just one time.
Because I guarantee it's everybody wants to change,
everybody wants to change.
For the most part.
A lot of people just don't know how.
I think that's looking at the clock.
I want to make sure we leave enough time for question and answers.
So try to drive towards a wrap up.
But I think,
Randy,
that's a perfect segue to what I'd like for the final question
to be is what can the community do to solve this issue of recidivism and in a
more finite level to support what's happening here in the state of Colorado?
And I,
I guess,
Travis,
I'd like to start with you because I think your perspective,
you know,
you've seen it coming back to your brother,
but you're also an entrepreneur yourself.
And so,
you know,
I think it's an interesting perspective of saying what can people in the
community do?
So I'm glad I was asked that question.
Uh,
indulge me for a second.
Everybody in this room put your hands up like this.
All right.
Just keep them up there for a second.
Think about this.
Imagine you just walked out of prison and you just applied for a job and they
told you they're going to call you back.
And this is the ninth time today.
Someone said they're going to call you back in your probation officer's calling
you asking you why you don't have a job.
Your kids,
mom or dad is screaming at you about not paying your bills.
You're living with your family and they're telling you how you're a loser and
how you're not going to work and then you're turning around and you're looking
at the world in how does the world see you with your hands up,
right?
You're vulnerable right now.
Your hands are up because it shows that you're giving up.
If we don't work together to change our society and help defy,
this is how we will be.
Some day we're having,
our hands are going to be up and there's going to be someone at the business end
of a handgun or a knife and they're going to be trying to take what we worked so
hard to kid because they felt like this that morning and they got sick of it.
We as a society need to get sick of people walking around with their hands in
the air.
We have to decide that we as a community can work together to bring our hands
down.
This is not about a handout.
This is about a hand up.
It's about you being in a position to change someone else's life with something
as simple as your time.
Simply listening to someone's story and saying,
Hey,
I can't promise you that you're going to get a job at Google,
right?
I can't promise you that you'll be a millionaire in five years,
but you know what I can do for you.
I can help you make a better decision so that you and I aren't talking inside of
a prison.
That's what you can do.
You can write a check.
That's true too.
You can,
I can just simply pay the problem away,
right?
And you can leave it on the shoulders of busy and Stacy and Bob and the
correctional folks here to take the money and try to do some good with it.
That works too.
But is that a solution to a longterm problem?
You guys deal with code and complex algorithms every day,
right?
I know.
I pay y'all.
We Google ad words.
I pay you for that and you guys work.
You're very welcome.
I paid for all of this.
Just so you know,
right this account brother hear me,
but imagine how complex it is
not having this.
I'm not trying to guilt you into anything.
I'm trying to get you to step back and say,
we as a society have to decide when enough is enough.
5% of the world's population,
yet 20% of them are incarcerated.
We've turned
punishment into a business
and business is good.
Is this who we are?
We define who we are by simply taking an opportunity to reach out to somebody
else.
If it's just your time,
if you're more comfortable with the money,
if you're more comfortable with a mentorship,
all of this is needed by the Fi.
Each one of you in this room have the power to do something.
No matter how small you think it is and all.
I'm asking you as somebody whose brother was blessed enough to be part of this,
please.
I'm asking from my brother,
for my mother,
my father,
and for every person that is not here,
please,
you can change our lives.
And all we're asking is please,
I have nothing else to say.
We're going to end it right there.
That was incredibly well said.
Travis,
thank you very much for that.
Let's give our panelists around.
Yeah,
pause
now.
We'll open it up to questions from the audience.
Anybody have a question?
Um,
I was just wondering,
you talked a little bit about what some of the roles that volunteers have.
Um,
but I was curious if you could give a little more an idea of what kinds of roles
and opportunities there are in terms of volunteering and,
and what you would do in those roles.
Sure.
Do you want me to answer?
Yeah,
why don't you take,
so volunteers have several opportunities to come into the facilities with us.
Um,
we have three big events throughout the eight month program that focused mostly
on Empathy Building and coaching on deliverables that they all create as a
result of the program.
So those are,
we have a one to one ratio those days.
So if we have 40 e I t s we'd have 40 volunteers come in.
And if I was your Eit,
I would show you my resume and you would give me coaching on how to better craft
my resume.
Right?
Um,
so those days are very structured and everyone's getting feedback on the same
deliverables.
Then we have our weekly classroom sessions,
which are every Tuesday at both Arkansas Valley correctional facility in car to
state penitentiary.
Um,
there are two and a half hours long and people come in and go over a variety of
different topics.
Um,
I always have volunteers say to me,
I'd like to come in and observe a class.
There's no such thing.
You get thrown right into it and have some of the most impactful,
very cool conversations.
Um,
okay.
The other is with our alumni groups.
So specifically if we talk about Travis,
his brother Darious,
um,
we have a lot of the guys who have longer or even life sentences who graduated
from our first cohort but are still very committed to change and transformation.
So we've put together an alumni program,
um,
where we continued to provide them kind of like think of it as like elective
courses where if you guys wanted to put together a presentation to show them,
I would set up the day and the time and I would call Bob and ask him to get me a
room and we bring all the alumni and bring in the volunteers and kind of create
something new which,
um,
oozy media actually did for us.
Um,
Travis is company,
so go dance has gone right there.
Gil,
Gil and Travis.
I think the other part,
cause we've talked primarily today about the in prison program.
Obviously Stacy hit on that inside out model,
but the aspect of the outside pieces,
the post release program and graduates who are coming back out into the
community,
Ronnie being one,
you know,
and having starting to run corporate workshops,
starting to run mentorships in the community to continue on that path of
assisting on entrepreneurship path,
assisting on life skills and that sort of thing.
And so,
you know,
it's,
it's certainly largely in prison right now,
but also out in the community,
there is a variety of opportunities as well.
Bob,
can I just jump in real quick?
Yeah,
I would just say,
um,
if you're wondering whether you're
okay
qualified to help or you would be good to help if this resonated with you at
all,
then you're totally qualified and you will be really good and you will think of
it.
Maybe it's going in for a volunteer opportunity and you giving,
but I promise you,
you will get so much more back.
And I know that's trite and Cliche,
but I,
I probably spend four or five days after prison.
I'm just processing,
just processing all the conversations I've had,
processing what I've learned about people processing,
putting my life in sort of a different perspective.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
it's a great deal of these jump on it.
You know,
that,
that's an arrestee point.
I just want to jump back in because we,
we have as a program,
we have,
we have two requirements for anybody who wants to come into our program or
prison.
And we have two requirements for any volunteer and anybody who wants to come
into our program,
when we go into a new prison,
I stand in front of them.
When I say we don't work with criminals,
we work with people who've done some bad stuff and we don't work with slackers.
And if you meet both of those boxes,
then you're welcome to come into the program.
And for volunteers,
the,
you know,
the numerous that I meet and talk to,
there's only two requirements.
One is showing up,
showing up is half the ballgame here.
And the other thing is coming in with an open mindset and I think it's back to
your point time.
If you're willing to come in with that open mindset,
that's where the interaction takes over.
Can I just say something real quick?
Um,
how about coming in?
You,
you know,
we're all human beings so we relate to each other in different ways.
You know,
it's not about being poor or rich or whatever,
you know,
and it's about being a human being.
Um,
you never know who you're gonna run into,
who one word could actually change your perspective.
You know,
I come from the streets and um,
you know,
my life was on the curves,
sound dope or doing whatever and you know,
with the Phi and you know,
the path that I was taking,
they absolutely helped me stand on that same curve just like this from the
streets,
looking at the streets and say,
hey,
you know,
turn around.
And when I turned around,
I seen the rest of the world and like how I want to be a part of that.
And maybe somebody who you talked to in prison or whatever you guys could do,
you know,
you guys might just be the one to change that one person who nobody could
thought it would be changed and let them see the rest of the world from that
same curve.
That's the best thing you've asked you to do it.
That's great.
I think we had a question over here.
Your courage and your end
did the archer madness and I feel it and I think most of this room feel it.
I think
people who work at Google
tend to have that in there.
It is part of our hiring criteria.
There's a Google enos hiring criteria that we often get through and we can sense
that empathy in others as well.
Uh,
that said,
what I wanted to ask really is,
uh,
how many of your graduates of the program actually come back and volunteer then
I'm very curious about that.
And also,
uh,
Trevor was it who meet Travis?
Travis.
Yeah.
It can be.
Trevor,
if you give me a discount on that brother.
I got your,
I got your ad words optimization all the writing.
I can help you with that.
Yeah.
Um,
on the first question,
I'll,
I'll jump in on that.
So I'm in Nebraska and in California,
um,
other defy states,
there's actually,
it is the work for those chapters that have come back.
So that's taking volunteering to the utmost level from that standpoint here in
Colorado.
Um,
Ronnie came with us.
We did a radio show a couple of weeks ago when Ryan,
he was with us two weeks ago.
We made a presentation to about 150 people in the community corrections industry
in Colorado.
And we brought another one of our graduates on Damien with us.
And Yeah.
Okay.
You know,
Brandon and Bob could talk about this more,
but this was all people who run the community corrections across Colorado,
the halfway houses,
the other facilities.
And they came up to us afterwards and they said,
we've never had somebody come back in
okay.
And present and they just couldn't believe it.
They were just baffled by the fact that Damien,
um,
was willing to come in and was willing to stand up there and be part of our
presentation and do the Q and a.
And so for us,
it's,
you know,
for us that's a key tenant of the overall program is to continue to pay it
forward.
Okay.
I had one final one,
if we have time that's there.
I,
I'd like Brian puts you on the spot a little bit,
but we talked about one of the tenants of the defy ventures Colorado program is
okay,
business ideation.
You have to develop a business,
you have to pitch a business.
In fact,
it's a requirement to graduate,
um,
to pitch a for profit business at a former business pitch competition.
What was your business idea and tell us a little bit about it.
My business idea was a taco truck.
Um,
I know it's,
you know,
Denver is saturated with them,
but why Taco truck has he on the Meos?
I feel like
the name alone is going to be catchy enough to go along with the quality of food
that I'm not going to produce.
This can be authentic Latin cuisine.
Uh,
Barbacoa Tacos,
Tacos,
history chair.
That was a line where a real authentic Mexican food land food,
um,
with a drink and some chips or whatever.
Um,
it's going to cost me about $7,300 to get,
you know,
to purchase a used car to grill is a freezer.
Um,
I have this idea that,
um,
going to a candy painted up and make it appealing to the eye.
I want to park it.
You know,
I'm going to focus on the nightlife in downtown Denver because you know,
when everybody gets out of the clubs are from going out,
you know,
everybody wants to go and get something to eat and everybody's trying to get
pushed out of the clubs and people want to interact with each other and figure
out what's going on next.
So,
you know,
I have this vision of a Yummy yummy on truck with some really good food on the
grill with some music still plan,
kind of keep it going a little bit afterwards.
Um,
and my plates are going to be like anywhere between like eight and $11 for a
plate of like three to five Tacos,
depending on what you get drinks.
We're going to be like dollar $52 extra.
Um,
seventh,
$300 is the truck,
or excuse me,
the trailer first month inventory,
licensing and permits and paint job parts.
You get a screen wrapped and the employees,
my employees will,
I will pay them just a hundred dollars a day.
They'll have to pay their own taxes.
But um,
yeah,
come in,
come.
And soon,
actually next summer I'd get out of the halfway house this summer.
So I'm going to have a whole year to work on saving the 7,300 and I plan on
launching Cinco de mio next year.
Um,
I'll have my first yum,
yum,
yum truck.
Like it's going to be official.
I'm going to do merchandising,
everything.
Know me.
I'm the,
I'm sure it's everything.
Um,
because you know,
when you guys are hungry and stuff,
you guys thinking about what to eat or you're going to be like,
what's,
what should we eat?
You want Mexican?
Oh,
yum.
Yummy.
Yum,
yum.
So we had these Tacos,
so there we go.
If we have anybody in the audience or anybody watching who,
uh,
has restaurant experience and wants to work with Ryan on helping him get his
business off the ground,
you know where to come to.
So I think we'll end right there.
I want to thank our panel.
Yeah.
Let's once again for coming up here.
What to say on behalf of everybody at the five ventures Colorado.
I want to thank Google in particular.
I want to thank Jess for giving us this opportunity to come in and tell you a
little bit about the work we do,
the work we're very passionate about,
and we're incredibly grateful that you had us here today.
So thank you.